You know a magic formula we can compute the ± term of the confidence level.
And here's how it looks like, where we've replaced the analytic variance
by the empirical variance over here, but otherwise, it's the same as before.
I just calculated this, and here's what I get.
For this sample, that means, we would say between the probability 0 and 1,
we believe most likely the coin was biased and has a 0.754 probability.
We are quite sure we have a confidence interval that's 0.42 wide on both sides.
In fact, it reaches beyond 1, which is a funny side effect of this in the normal assumption.
This is the interval in which we are uncertain about what the correct value of the coin is.
In fact, this one does include 0.5--it could be that this coin is perfectly unbiased.
0.75-0.42 is much smaller than 0.5. Obviously, it's a small sample.
Let's do the same thing for a larger sample, and this one is a quiz for you.
Here's the sample. I've ordered it. There's three tails and seven heads.
I want you to just compute for me the mean plus/minus this confidence interval with the term.
Please give me both numbers.